あーらーん
ああああああああ
ブーブー本日知ったんですけどもう今日うちパティちゃん noon アイコンじゃあ
外れ社長ですね佳境ですか8月の30肇社長チャンネルをつくったのが5年前のはっ
月の30日だったらしくて今日で外れ者通算での開示として5年目らしいです
ありがとうございます本当にここまでハズレ冊を応援してくださった方本当に
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
まあ市内でちょっと非常に最中の話をさせていただきますととても忙しいなかなか
ちょっと忙しくてですねもう実はここ3日間4日くらい動画とってなくてなかなかこう
ちょっとゆっくりで本当のあの質問コーナー申し訳ない質問マネーもようやく選びに
至るんですけども後答えるだけなんで youtube はじめてちょっと最高レベル
ぐらいのちょっと今時間がなくてあんま
で時間を見つけて必ずやりますのですまねぇ
すまねぇちょっと今は毎日の投稿より頑張らなければいけないことがあるので許して
くださいと言うけどちょっと5周年なにしようかなって思ったんですけども
特にないすいません明日も朝早いのでちょっといっ
程度にありません適当にてのそもそもね俺って適当な動画だったと思うんでちょっと
適当にいくね
なっかりというわけでちょっと今日はとりあえずね5年間 youtube やってみ
てちょっと思った事感じた事とかね得るちょっとかるーく話していければいいなと思っ
ておりますまあとりあえず
本当に見てくださるみなさんには感謝しております
いつもありがとう本当にまず5年間やってをもっと bot バーまぁ見てくださる
みなさんがいてこその
肇社長だと思うのでこれからも引き続き応援していただければ嬉しいなと思っており
ますまあけど
[音楽]
1斤が youtube すごいっすね金遣い荒いはなんやもうたくさんですよね最近
はねもうほんとユーチューバーっていうもの自体がすごい有名になってきていろんな人
が増えてそれはもう2のいろんな動画が出てくるんですけど
まあもうなんかうわソイヤッちゃうかみたいな人の事言えないはそれほど言えないよう
なことがこの l んですけども他の人僕から見るとね
すげーがそんな金使っちゃうみたいな激しいなあみたいな1つと増えてきててまぁ良い
か悪いかで言うと
突然のいいんじゃねえかなと思いますが僕はもう5年経っても変わらず自分のしたい
ことをしていくだけなので自分に素直に僕のやりたいことを2実にやっていこうと思い
ますそれで怒られることもよくあるんですけども守るべきところは守りつつねこう年間
でも動画納言を作ったっけ1400本ぐらいちょっと作ったと思うんですけどやーもー
ねーすー
多いね自分で言ったら何なんですけどもなかなかの数をつくってきたなと思っており
ます
あとは何だろう
特に話すことね保全間行ってみてかクオリティが上がったと思う
僕だけじゃないですよ僕だけじゃないんですけれども基本的に何かユーチューバーの
作る動画って言うもののこうなんか
レベルが上がった動画の内容も編集とかもすごい上がったと思いますか
まぁそれはいいじゃんいいんですけど逆に考えるとしょうがない動画だすと
こうなんかウェイーってなるんでなんかね大マンクオリティ高い動画をつければいいや
と僕も思ってたんですけど最近まで描いとそうでもないなっていう youtube
って本来こうなんか違うに出せるのがいいところだったと思うんでまぁちょっと消防団
に動画とかも必要なんじゃないかなとちょっとこの5年間を通していろいろ考えた末で
たどり着いた答えがそんな感じでした全然僕より youtube で長い人が
たくさんいると思うんですけど
5年間でるって人もそうそういないと思うのでなるべく前に出せる人でねまあ5年を
迎えてここから先も youtube 頑張っていこうと思っていくんですけども
もっともっとクオリティ高いっていうということではなくもっともっと自分のしたい
ぞうがやってみたいこと
できれば自分らしく頑張っていければいいなと思っております
ね
うんかなかったなぁ
ところぞ
a というわけでちょっと実はバタバタしています肇社長で性欲はびっくりした
まあほんとね色んな youtube あの増えたこの5年間で辞めてった
ユーチューバーもいたしいまだに登録者が少なくても続けているユーチューバー部か
知っています
逆に肛門いきなりバーンて出てきたユーチューバーもいろいろいるんですけども
すごい公を取り巻く環境が目まぐるしく変わっている中でも
終わらず撮りたい動画楽しそうだなと思った動画を撮っていければいいなと思っており
ます本当いつも応援してくれるみんなありがとう
今後もよろしくお願いします
とりま
時間見つけ質問コーナー頑張るはじゃん
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ